good evening doctor
no no don't stand up and
yes i am who you think
i am let's not make any more of this
than it is you know my number
and i know enough about you to make a
duplicate
that even your mother wouldn't be able
to tell you apart from the real you
no that's not a threat
just a fact
now as to my business here
it seems you have stumbled upon
something above your clearance
well no stumbled isn't the right word
dug up perhaps
and you're getting to the point where
further digging would end up
in some fairly lethal gunshot wounds
[Music]
this would be a very sad state of
affairs
as you are otherwise quite a good
researcher
therefore you are getting something very
few people in the foundation ever
get an explanation
yes we were alerted when you first
started digging
into scp-001 every researcher who has
been around for a while looks into it
most are satisfied when they uncover the
angel with the flaming sword
it's buried under enough levels
but then you started looking into the
factory
and that is when i knew you wouldn't
stop
so here it is
plain and simple the factory
is scp-001
but it will never be written up it was a
choice i made early on in the creation
of the foundation
and a choice i still stand by
you researchers are far too curious
i'm not sure which scares me worse the
fact that we'll never understand the
factory
or that one day we will
ah well i'm sure you're eager to learn
more the factory was built in 1835.
back then it was known as the anderson
factory named after
james anderson a rather well-to-do
industrialist it was built in oh
let's just say america
and was the largest factory ever
designed
a good mile across at its widest three
stories tall throughout
with a special seven-story tower by the
front gate that anderson lived in
it was designed to be the ultimate
factory
capable of taking care of everything
including the housing
of workers people could be born
work live and die
without ever leaving the confines of the
factory
and work they did on everything from
cattle raising and slaughtering to
textiles
to everything else under the sun
now no one knows whether james anderson
was
actually a satan worshiper it's just as
likely that he followed some kind of
pagan gods
what is known as that he was very exact
in the building of his factory and in
the placement
of his machinery within it survivors
claimed that the floor was engraved with
arcane symbols
that were only visible when blood flowed
across them
but then the survivors claimed a lot of
things
what is known is that anderson made his
money in the blood
and sweat and sometimes body parts
of the lower class his journals indicate
he thought of them as
less than human being put on this earth
only to serve his will of course
at that time no one knew about his
predilections
and so people flocked to the factory a
place to both work
and live at the same time well of course
people wanted him never mind the harsh
hours
working conditions sadistic security
force
and all the rest factory workers were
forced to work
16-hour days work only shutting down on
sundays
between sunrise and sunset workers were
not given individual rooms
instead sharing rooms with eight other
people
sleeping in shifts of three medical
attention was unheard of
if you were injured in the course of
your duties which most people were
you were expected to just keep working
anyone too injured to work was dragged
off by the security
never to be heard from again for 40
years
the anderson factory cranked out all
sorts of things for people
meat clothes weapons
never mind that the beef might be mixed
with human don't care that the weapons
were forged in blood
no attention you'd be paid that the
clothes were dyed with
well you get the idea rumors
leaked out but the products were so good
why bother until someone got out
i never met the brave soul who managed
to escape but she did
managed to meet with president grant and
in 1875 he enlisted
my aide at the time i was
well it doesn't matter i will say i was
in the military
kind of and that my people were the same
150 good men and some few women
who were often given jobs that weren't
supposed to be common knowledge
we had been clearing out some
confederate holdouts
and some of the worst things we found
down south
so we did some research and didn't like
what we saw
and went in loaded for bear
i don't actually remember much about the
night it all went down
most of it blends together in my head i
get flashes
sometimes people chained to the line
living next to the dead and damned
hard to tell which was which children
working underneath machines
majority of the flesh scoured from their
bones by the great wheels and cogs
and other things
no i'm i'm all right
i haven't thought about that night for a
very long time
the security force wasn't much of a
problem but then
anderson's creations showed up
he'd been taking the injured workers and
well
experimenting on them
men if you could call them men with
multiple arms sewn together some
combined with animals
horrible monstrosities out of mankind's
worst nightmares they kept coming
wave after wave of not quite living
creatures
i lost a lot of good people that night
and then we found out anderson's
breeding pits
girls as young as eight chained to the
walls
forced to be nothing more than
i'm sorry even today more than a century
later
the memory makes me see red when we
finally
found anderson cowering in his office we
hung him from his tower window
with his own entrails as he died
he laughed saying it didn't matter
we could kill him but his factory the
factory would go on he was still
laughing
24 hours later when we finally cut him
down
had him drawn and quartered and then
burned the remains the entire time he
uttered blasphemies that i don't
like to think about we spent a week
cleaning that place out
freeing the workers putting down the
things we found in the basements
and many lightless rooms
we pulled out things that were useful
and stalked them in a house near the
gate
tried to make sense of everything
150 of us went into that hell pit that
night
and only 93 came out by the end of the
week
we were down to 71 but the things we
found
in there my god well you've
been with the foundation a while they
wouldn't seem as amazing to you but
we found toy guns that shot real bullets
a yo-yo that would flay the skin from
anyone it touched
hammers that only worked on human flesh
a breed of skeletal horse
that ran faster than anything we'd ever
seen
cloaks that seemed woven from the night
itself
and let men access a shadowy dimension
that
i get away from myself we found tools
both wondrous and horrible
and we were faced with a choice
i gathered my highest ranking well
we'll call them officers to me
we tried to figure out what we would do
they all had opinions
the chaplain had gone a little crazed
thought all these
objects must be miracles sent from god
holy relics to be worshiped
marshall and his little today dawkins
thought there was a fortune to be made
here making and selling these things
to the highest bidder the engine we
called
base due to his deep speaking voice
he called these things an abomination
and declared that we should
hunt down and destroy everything we
could find
and smith thought we should take
this stuff back to the president
the only one without an opinion was the
old man but he never said much of
anything anyways
we argued for hours days trying to work
it out
me i thought we were sitting on a gold
mine all right but
that we could use these things these
objects to hunt down some of the scary
things we'd ran into down south
the other monsters this world has to
offer
and use this factory for good as a place
to contain these things
find a way to make them work for our
fellow man or at least
protect our fellow man from having to
deal with them
i'm sure you could figure out what
happened the chaplain snuck away in the
night with his devotees
taking a couple of small items with them
marshall we kicked out when we found him
abusing his authority
he promised he'd get revenge and that
little duck and [ __ ] led the rest of the
group off with some of the juicier
items base and his people tried to light
the whole damn thing on fire
then just left when it didn't work
and smith left to report back to the
president i did manage to get him to
promise that he'd tell grant that the
factory had been destroyed
i had big plans for that place
of course it was kind of hard to follow
through on big plans when you only have
12
other people to work with but it was a
start
and it worked for a while we had these
amazing toys finding people to work with
us was
easy back then going off the grid was as
simple as
leaving town we knew what we wanted
we knew what we could be
leventhal set out getting us backing
a simple invention here some
well-invested money there
it all worked out white and jones set
out getting us
other backing in our previous work we'd
found out some interesting things about
people some
secrets that powerful men didn't want
getting out
and with our new position helping keep
secrets
we got more people asking us to deal
with their secrets
blackmail is a dirty word
but it works bright argent
and luminous got to work cataloging the
items
light and bright's wife the nurse they
made sure we kept ourselves
healthy no it's just
remembering light she had such unusual
ideas about
hygiene for the time brilliant woman
xov fleischer and karnoff dealt with
training the troops
tesla and tamlin were in charge of
figuring out how to take
advantage of the items without making it
obvious
we were amazing the city we built around
the factory
which we took to calling site alpha was
self-supporting the agents
researchers operatives of all sorts not
by those names of course but
those positions we expanded
i'm sorry i'm an old man
i know i don't look it but the body lies
the mind doesn't always remember right
and sometimes i get lost in my memories
things get confused but the long and
simple of this
is we use the factory
it always seemed to have more empty
rooms to store things in
back then that was the word for them
things
no skips then no we thought we had the
factory tamed
that's one of the reasons i refuse to
quit this job
if there is anything i can do here it's
remind
people that we will never tame these
things
contain them yes but as we saw with abel
tamed them never
after a decade or so we were pretty
organized the 13 original of us were
called by numbers not names
we knew how to make things work and if a
thing or two vanished inside of the
factory still
and the occasional d-class what
yes we had d-class back then
disposables that's where the d
comes from had to have some things
to test on tesla and tamlin were both
very firm about that but
yes sometimes we lost
people who didn't matter adam
sorry dr bright was fond of saying it
was the factory taking its toll
you can't get something from nothing
1911 was when it all went wrong
things we called them fairies
an entire race of things living beside
us
they could look the same as you or i the
only obvious difference
was an allergy to iron that's why we
called them
fairies no you haven't heard of them
why because it's the one time the
foundation wiped out an entire
race of things root and branch
and i am the one who did it
we'd been hunting them for some time
we'd
run into them a time or two before come
out on top
so when a certain royal asked us for
help of course
we were eager to get them in our debt
we've
always loved having people in our debt
we sent a team to help out take care of
what we thought was a hunting party
the next time we saw them their heads
were on poles
attached to the saddles of the creatures
the fairies rode when they attacked the
factory
it was horrible three words
but they convey so much i've
never
i'm sorry please
give me a moment
i've never told this part to anyone
you should count yourself lucky and if
you ever
tell anyone of what i am about to impart
onto you
i will not just kill you
but i will kill everyone who shares your
dna
in the worst ways possible you'll think
procedure 110
montauk is a walk in the park compared
to what i will do to you
we lost the things came they destroyed
us rode over our emplacements
slaughtered our people shrugged off our
weapons
like they were nothing i watched my
thirteen go down
left and right just trying to hold
the factory and i
i their leader their friend
their father figure godfather to the
brights for young children
confidant sometimes lover
always the confessor i ran
i ran like a scared little schoolboy
deep into the dark
guts of the factory
i was chased by the things always
just one step ahead
i could hear them behind me feel their
breath
on my neck
i came to a door i'd never seen before
a bronze door covered in arabic script
of some sort
i've never been one for languages
especially not the curvy [ __ ] the
muscle men use
but i didn't care they were coming for
me
and i threw open the door and dived
through it everything inside was
different there was a feeling of
peace that nothing could hurt me here
the light was this dark red but it still
felt right my ears were filled with a
steady thrumming of a gigantic
heartbeat and in front of me
were the remains of anderson
it spoke to me then but i'll be damned
if i could tell you
exactly what it said what it told me was
more meaning than exact it offered me
hope it told me
told me that each of the things that we
had used from the factory no matter what
we did with them fed it helped it grow
but if the fairies took the factory they
would
destroy it and we couldn't have that
it offered me a deal
it could remove this event make it have
never happened
all i needed to give it was us
i didn't want to i knew it was a bad
idea but then
i saw them again my family my friends
dead by the hands of those bastards
i agreed it smiled i found myself
once more upon the ramparts watching the
horde of fairies crest the hill
my foundation alive once more
in my hands was a weapon i won't bore
you with the details
but we slaughtered them and with these
new weapons continued
to slaughter them everywhere they lived
everywhere they bred
my fellow o5s questioned my decision
thinking we should save some
in case we might ever need them i
overruled them
we moved away from the factory shut it
down
moved our things out of there we changed
the name from things
to special containment protocols
focusing on containing them not
anything else
the others were curious but understood i
had
my reasons i boarded up the factory
locked it shut buried it under a ton of
rubble
saying it was too dangerous i thought
thought i'd gotten away with it until i
found a thing
under my desk one of the old toy guns
that shot real bullets
and it had the factory label on it
i've sent people in from time to time to
see what it might be doing
last time i sent people in to look there
was nothing there
we keep finding factory items out there
i
can't help but think of how many more we
don't find
the people who use them keep it hidden
i think back to the body telling me how
each item used gave energy to the
factory
i never asked it energy for what i don't
think i want to know
what do we give it d-class mostly
where did you think those bodies went
there's a place
bodies are left and they vanish
everyone thinks i'm a genius for
figuring it out
sometimes sometimes i
have to feed it other things researchers
agents they never know what's coming it
just reaches out and takes them but
in the end we are doing more good by
being here whatever the factory wants
whatever it
is we're doing good here and i have to
believe
that and now you know
are you happy i didn't think so
why tell you i'm getting old everett
should i die someone will have to keep
feeding it
maybe you'll be different maybe you'll
figure out how to stand
up to it but
i doubt it
you